[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
greg mcelroy abc espn college football
analyst former alabama quarterback led
bama to a national title in 2010. greg
was on the call for notre dame florida
state on sunday night he's got texas at
arkansas that will be
coming up this saturday at 7 eastern
greg thanks for joining us great to see
you again let me start with our poll
question you can win a national
championship
or you can be the heisman trophy winner
which one would you take since you've
won a national title would you trade in
the 2010 national championship to be
named the heisman trophy winner
i think your ability to live on forever
uh as an individual would be better
as the heisman trophy winner dan but i
would never trade in my national
championship knowing that that
collectively
were able to earn that together you know
just like you and the danettes like
would you really trade an individual
but is it better to achieve
hold on for a second we got uh a bad
connection i think i actually heard him
say that he would rather win the
national title than the heisman so i
know there was a bad connection there
greg mcelroy back with us all right greg
so there there was a communication you
know connection problem because i i
actually thought you said you'd rather
have the national title than win the
heisman
i i love that you're trying to say as if
i was crazy in answering that i said i
would never trade my national
championship been for anything the
heisman would potentially make me think
twice but no
the national championship is something
that we earned collectively dan while
yes as a heisman trophy winner you get
to cash in in nissan commercials you get
to do a lot of amazing things and your
individual legacy will live on forever
but collectively doing something
together a lot of the national
championship man come on i'm not trading
that in no way
when you go back to tuscaloosa do you
have to buy dinner
depends on how nice the restaurant is
and uh knowing the the quality of the
restaurants that we have in the
beautiful city that is tuscaloosa yes i
have to have to buy dinner quite often
uh but yes i i have i've had to buy
dinner drinks however um usually those
come
free of charge uh as long as you leave a
pretty decent sized tip
but when you played at alabama you
didn't have to buy a dinner or buy
drinks
that isn't accurate because nil at that
point as i appreciate you trying to
connect the dots and lead me down this
dangerous path every time i come in on
here i go viral for something remarkably
inappropriate
and some comment will live on an infamy
forever because of something i say with
you guys so no i'm not gonna take debate
on that one under no circumstance but
name image and likeness your final
season at alabama how do you think you
could have cashed in
uh i think i would have done pretty well
um
i don't know to what extent because some
of the numbers that have been thrown out
here at that point social media was
early right it was very much in its
infancy like you couldn't use facebook
to create a revenue stream twitter was
just getting underway
so yeah while you had following the
access to the player and the and
the people would not been has been as
significant but yeah on signing
autographs and appearances
um it probably would have been an excess
of six figures uh probably fairly
comfortably too
when thinking about the promotional
opportunities that you would have had
within the state i mean we were the
first national champions in
17 years
so
being the starting quarterback it
probably would have been fairly
lucrative who had the worst weekend in
college football
the acc
as a whole the pac-12 would be a really
close runner-up given
the
inexplicable loss that washington had as
a top 20 team as a team that prides
himself on their offensive line getting
pushed around by an fcs opponent but i
would say those two by far and away had
the most disappointing performances the
fact and here's just to put the acc's
performance into perspective
a lot of people are saying the finest
moment for the acc came on sunday night
and what was a moral victory by one of
their blue blood schools
that to me gives you a sense of where
the acc is at and i'm not saying florida
state wasn't impressive they were
remarkably impressive the teams made a
ton of progress and i'm proud of them
for the for the effort they put on the
field on sunday night but that gives you
a perspective of where that league is
right now with the top to bottom lack of
quality that they have throughout
what about lsu losing at ucla
i can't say that was surprising man i
mean lsu had struggled on the defense
side of the football last year but i
think this was as much about ucla being
legit
and this is a ucla team in year number
four under chip kelly that started a
bunch of freshmen four years ago and
were awful
but then you started to see them make
some strides and then last year we
actually did their game against usd dan
and they were a team that i thought to
myself like man if not for covid what
could have been
but with the challenges that they had
and the pac-12 not starting until early
november and having a weird fall camp
it was almost as if they
had their growth stunted
as a team and as an organization but now
fast forward this year and all the
pieces are starting to come together
they have a lot of veterans they've
added a couple pieces via the transfer
portal and ship has created a scheme
running the football that is almost
impossible to defend especially with the
running backs running as hard as they
are and a quarterback that can carve you
up occasionally when on the move
throwing the football so i actually
think
last weekend's performance while it was
a disappointing performance for lsu i
actually came away equally impressed by
what ucla did
how hyped up should alabama fans be with
bryce young
i don't think alabama fans need any
help hyping themselves up
every year this is the greatest team in
the history of the world
but it is
this is obviously after a weekend in
which you saw some teams really not put
together complete performances i mean
dan against quality opponents you could
probably count on two hands how many
really dominant performances there were
by teams on both sides of the football
like from what one team might have done
offensively they struggled defensively
that would be say
uh let's say oklahoma using them as an
example well some teams
dominated defensively and struggled
offensively will use georgia so i mean
there's plenty of teams that are looking
at themselves in the mirror on monday
saying man we left
a lot of opportunities on the field on
both sides of the football alabama was
one of the few teams
that really looked complete
both offensively and defensively and if
you want to go one step further in the
special teams game as well so uh it
should be no surprise that alabama with
the talent that they have
they're always going to be as good as
anybody in college football but to be
that good that early
i think that was a little bit of a
warning shot to the rest of the of the
world that's watching them play at a
level that not many people can replicate
does the targeting rule work
who yes it does but we need to do a
better job as a sport making sure people
understand it like there are
broadcasters
and people and coaches that don't
understand the rule and i think that's
occasionally frustrating because people
have a difficult time understanding
why it's called targeting and and just
because it's helmet to helmet dan
doesn't mean it's targeting it doesn't
mean it's an automatic objection
and it doesn't mean that the refs are
against your team it's not it's
the helm of the helmet happens almost on
every single play
but in order for it to be targeting you
have to have one an indicator which is
initiating contact with the crown of
your helmet
or you have to have a launch
or an upward thrust so think about a
player launching upward towards the head
or neck area of a defenseless player
those are the two indicators
if it's one of those two indicators
it can potentially be targeting
depending on where the contact and the
forcible contact takes place so i think
we need to do a better job as a sport
educating people and i don't think
people want to be educated
in some ways people don't really want to
learn the rule they just don't like
that it's not the barbaric ronnie lot
i'm going to take your head off across
the middle type of game that it once was
just not that way we're trying to keep
players safe and we have actually been
seen
changes in players behavior now week one
week two week three
you see a lot more targeting fouls
because guys aren't as dialed in to
tackling fundamentals but as the season
goes along you'll see less and less so
yes last night was eye opening four
targeting fouls in the first half alone
in that louisville ole miss game some of
which were inexcusable where guys are
just leading and spearing with the crown
of their helmet so it works
but
i think we need to do a better job
making sure people understand why it's
targeting and how we reach the targeting
rule and why a guy got ejected and it
could potentially affect them not just
for this game but for the next game as
well we're talking to greg mcelroy
former alabama quarterback he's a
college football analyst for espn and
abc you were on the call for notre dame
and florida state how would you sum up
mac milton's comeback story
man was that was that crazy or what i
mean you as someone that was watching
the game and just sitting there because
i can tell you what it felt like in the
booth i would like to know from your
perspective dan as someone that's
consumed a ton of sports what was it
like knowing the story and seeing him
back out there almost orchestrating one
of the most amazing comebacks we've ever
seen
well
i remember having him on the show when
he was at central florida and then he
had that devastating injury and it's
almost like a ghost reappeared in a
different uniform and you go oh my god
mac milton is back on the sidelines and
then he goes into the game and whoever
your director was on that game showing
his parents
that that just made it all work because
you saw that parents can only do so much
you're watching your son you probably
deep down don't want him to be playing
because he nearly lost his leg weren't
even sure if he'd even be able to walk
now he's playing
and you're there watching it in person
with the doctor who performed the
surgery
yeah that
it's crazy i mean that that's something
out of a movie
it it's almost as if if you put it in a
movie dan
people would say that's too far-fetched
that's the ludicrous it would never
happen but it was happening right there
right before our very eyes and it was it
was unbelievable and to see the shots of
his mom i want to give credit to jeff
evers and our amazing camera crew i mean
jeff evers our director i mean he to
capture that moment and to see his mom
uncontrollably crying
and then at the end of the drive as soon
as her son got off the field you finally
saw her exhale you can only imagine what
the anxiety was like i was nervous i
mean i would no rooting interest
whatsoever i was a nervous wreck like oh
my god don't hit this kid like give him
a black jersey he's untouchable don't
hit him you know so it was like a level
of anxiety that was tough to really
comprehend while also
trying to be professional within the
broadcast and yet internally
all of us rooting for mckenzie not to
win the game it was just just rooting
for his health rooting for his
satisfaction of completing this long
arduous comeback man it was insane i've
never had an experience like that in the
booth it was almost as a it was almost
an out-of-body experience to see that
and
uh of course he did he didn't win the
game
notre dame hung on and did what they
needed to do down the stretch but man
just to see the magic in the air that
night on the first night in which
they're playing a football game in
tallahassee after bobby bowdy's found
his passing and then you just have the
magic of mackenzie milton who has always
been a magical player but a magical
player now on a completely reconstructed
leg
it was something i will never forget it
was absolutely unbelievable and you're
100 right it was a movie script we were
living out right before our very eyes on
national television
uh if you see jeff evers tell him uh
great job uh i wasn't sure who the
director was but uh knowing jeff at the
mothership uh when i worked there uh
congrats to him that that was great and
uh we're having mac milton on the show
tomorrow so
uh should be fun uh you'll be tell him
he may tell him as if he is he didn't
need any more fans but he got about
eight million more fans on sunday night
after the performance and just the heart
that he displayed it was unbelievable
greg great to talk to you again thanks
for joining us uh tell joe tessa tour we
said hello
sounds good man so good to talk to you
guys miss y'all hope y'all doing well
that's greg mcelroy he'll be on the call
with uh
let's see he's got arkansas and texas at
arkansas that'll be coming up saturday
night 7 30 eastern